this tutorial is about exploratory fact
analysis
and we get started right now
so the first question is what is
exploratory fact analysis
exploratory fact analysis is a method
that aims at uncovering structures in
your data
if you have a data set with many
variables it is possible that some of
them are interrelated for example they
correlate with each other
these correlations are the basis of fact
analysis
the task of fact analysis is to divide
the variables into groups of those
variables which are most correlated to
each other
so the goal of fact analysis is to
divide variables into groups
variables that are highly correlated
should be separated from those which are
less correlated to each other
within the groups the variables should
correlate as high as possible
between the groups the correlation
should be as slow as possible
but first let's talk about what factor
means
in fact analysis the so-called factor
can be seen as a hidden variable
influencing several actually observed
variables
therefore we have our observed variables
on the one side and behind them we have
factors that influence these variables
or let's say in other words
several variables are observable
phenomena of less underlying factors
so now a brief summary for you
fact analysis combines variables that
are highly correlated with each other
it is assumed that this correlation is
due to an unmeasurable variable called
factor
now let's look at an example
one possible question could be
can different personality traits such as
outgoing couriers sociable or helpful be
grouped into personality types such as
conscientiousness extraversion or
openness
in order to find it out let's say you
created a small survey with data tab
survey you now want to find out if some
of the traits correlate strongly with
each other
and if they can be described by a factor
so your question is if some of the
traits outgoing sociable hard-working
dutiful warm-hearted or helpful
correlate with each other and thus can
be described by an underlying factor
let's say you have interviewed 20 people
and the results are in your excel
spreadsheet you can find a link to the
excel spreadsheet in the video
description now let's look at the little
preview
at the end of fact analysis we could
then conclude that outgoing and sociable
can be described by the factor
extraversion hardworking and dutiful by
the factor conscientious and
warm-hearted and helpful by
agreeableness but how do we get these
results
now we have to go through it step by
step
in the first step we calculate the fact
analysis for the example
and then i explain to you the procedure
of factor analysis on the basis of these
results for the calculation of factor
analysis we use data tab you can find a
link to data tab in the video
description
first we click on the statistics
calculator and then we paste our data
into this table in order to do this we
simply click on empty table first and
then we copy our own data into the table
now we have inserted our data into the
table and we click on the
tab then down here we see the six
variables that we want to use
now we want to calculate the fact
analysis for all six variables
so we just click on all six variables so
that's outgoing sociable hardworking
dutiful
warm-hearted and helpful
what we now have to do is to choose the
number of factors in our example we
choose the number of three why we assume
that there are three factors will be
explained later
first we take a look at the correlation
matrix in a correlation matrix we can
see how strongly the individual traits
correlate with each other
so for example
outgoing has a strong correlation with
sociable
but outgoing and hardworking do not
strongly correlate with each other so
with the help of the correlation matrix
we get an overview of the correlations
between the traits in addition the
correlation matrix is the basis for
calculating the so-called eigenvalues
and eigenvectors
but we'll look at this later
in our example we have six variables now
so we can have a maximum of six factors
in this table the factors are sorted by
size the first factor is the one that
can explain
most of the variance
and the last one is the one that
explains
least of the variance the first factor
on its own explains
31.2 percent of the total variance of
the six variables the second vector on
its own explains
24.7 percent and finally the sixth
factor alone only explains
3.44
of the total variance
on the right side we can see the
cumulative percentages if we use the
first two factors we can already explain
55.9 percent of the total variance of
the six variables
and if we use the first three factors
we can already explain 78
of the total variance which is quite a
lot
therefore if we take instead of six
original variables just these three
factors we can explain 78.6
of the original variable but now we come
to the big question how many factors do
we need
fact analysis does not give you a clear
answer to this question but in order to
determinate the number of factors needed
there are two common methods and we will
go through them right now
so how many factors do we need now for
both methods to find that out the
eigenvalues are sorted by size and
plotted on a graph
on the x-axis we have the number of
factors 1 to 6
and on the y-axis we have the
eigenvalues let's start with the
eigenvalue criterion with the eigenvalue
criterion you simply look at how many
eigenvalues are greater than 1 which
gives you the number of factors in this
case two factors are greater than one
accordingly in this case the number of
factors would be two
the second method is the so-called scree
test which is a graphical method here
you simply look in the diagram
where there is a kink or a so-called
elbow
you can see the elbow also at this point
so accordingly this method also leads us
to the result of two factors
but in practice of course the diagram
does not always look so
nice let's just have a look at the
diagram of our example it's not always
that easy to interpret the diagram
in our case the diagram looks like this
and here of course we cannot read a kink
or an elbow and we should simply go the
way of the eigenvalue criterion
so we just look at how many of the
factors have an eigenvalue greater than
one
and we use that as the number of factors
in this case we have three factors that
have an eigenvalue greater than one and
therefore we take three as the number of
our factors once the number of factors
is determined the communalities can be
calculated the communalities indicate
how much variance of the variables can
be explained by the three factors
for example of the variable outgoing
77.5
of the variance can be explained purely
by the three factors or let's look at
the variable sociable here we can see
that
88.3 percent of the variance can be
explained purely by the three factors so
now there are three terms that we have
heard over and over again which is
factor loading eigenvalue and
commonality before we come to the final
interpretation of the results i would
now like to go into those three terms in
an example what is the factor loading
the factor loading indicates for example
how high the correlation between
outgoing and extraversion is an
eigenvalue indicates for example how
much variance can be explained by the
factor conscientiousness of all
variables
and finally the commonalities indicate
for example
how much variance of the six variables
can be explained by the three factors
so now i cheated a bit we don't really
have such a nice result yet
in order to get such a nice result for
example to assign exactly one factor to
the variables
there are two more steps necessary and
we look at them now
so let's output the component matrix now
the component matrix gives us the
loadings of the factors on the variables
this is the first factor the second
factor and the third factor
for example we can read here that the
first factor correlates with the
variable outgoing with 0.67
or the first factor correlates with the
variable sociable with
0.8 since the first factor explains most
of the variance the values of the first
factor are the largest in terms of
amount
of course this is not quite optimal
because we actually want to distribute
the individual variables among the three
factors
and we do not want a large number of
variables to be bundled in the first
factor
actually we want to assign the variables
to the factors and thus form the groups
in this case however many variables
would be assigned to the first factor
therefore this component matrix usually
cannot be interpreted in a meaningful
way and we need one last step
and that is the rotation with the
rotation matrix
there are different methods for this
rotation but the most common is the
analytical vary max rotation vary max
rotation is used to analytically ensure
that per factor certain variables load
as high as possible and the other
variables load as low as possible this
result is obtained when the variance of
the factor loadings per factor is as
high as possible in the rotated table we
can see that ongoing and sociable have
the largest value in terms of amount for
the first factor and are thus assigned
to the first factor
hardworking and dutiful have the
greatest value in terms of amount in the
third factor and are therefore assigned
to the third factor
and finally
warm-hearted and helpful have the
highest scores on the second factor and
are thus assigned to the second factor
the factor analysis does not tell us
how to name the factors
it is the task of the researcher to
determine these names
i've used a simplified form of the
so-called big five personality traits
here so it is also easy to name the
factors in this case for example we
could describe the variables outgoing
and sociable with the factor
extraversion
hardworking and dutiful with the factor
conscientiousness and finally
warm-hearted and helpful with the factor
agreeableness
after this procedure we have now
assigned the six personality traits to
three factors
now let's go through the whole procedure
again for a short repetition so in the
first step we copied our data into the
table and set the number of factors
initially the first thing we got was the
correlation matrix the correlation
matrix gave us an overview of how the
different personality traits correlate
from the correlation matrix the
eigenvalues and eigenvectors can be
calculated and further we could get the
table of the explained total variance
then we use the eigenvalue criterion to
determine the number of factors and here
we got the result of 3. if we had used a
different value for the number of
factors at the beginning we would simply
change it now into three further datadeb
calculated the communalities for us and
the component matrix and finally we got
the rotated component matrix as an
output in the rotated component matrix
we could then see which personality
trait can be assigned to which factor
so finally we found out that outgoing
and sociable can be assigned to the
first factor because there were the
largest values hardworking and dutiful
can be assigned to the third factor and
finally warm-hearted and helpful will be
assigned to the second factor
i hope you enjoyed the video bye and see
you next time